Okay, so in this section, we need to start
with generating Arruco marker sets
to do LED wall alignment.
Now to get started,
after you've completed your camera calibration
for the lens file asset,
this lens file will hold and contain
your lens distortion and nodal point offset,
and is gonna be used as part of your LED wall
alignment with camera tracking.
What we're doing right now is the LED wall alignment.
We're gonna build the Arrucos markers
that are gonna use to create points
from a library of specific images
that we can use to calculate the actual distance
of the LED wall and adjust it
so it's in the real world space.
Now, this change on the latte stage
is gonna be very minor.
It's gonna be very small.
You're not gonna see much of it,
but it is gonna be something that will actually calibrate.
And it's always done after completing
the camera calibration for your lens file asset.
So making sure that your lens distortion
and nodal point offset are completed
before we do the LED wall alignment.
Now, we just wanna verify the plugins that are available,
which is our LED wall calibration
and our live link over end display.
And then we're gonna move into our content browser
and start to create some folders.
So let's jump into the engine and get started with that.
So let's make sure we're in our calibration folder.
And you can see I've got checkerboard, lens file,
media profiles and nodal point.
Let's go ahead and create a brand new folder here
by right click and new folder.
And this one is going to be our Arruco underscore wall
textures.
Now with that open,
we can just make sure that we are in that folder,
but we need to make sure we have access to the NDC
that we're gonna be working with here as well.
So first thing I'm gonna do is I'm gonna double click
on my NDC asset to make sure that that is active.
And with that active,
I'm gonna move right back to my calibration folder
so that I can make sure that my textures from my Arrucos
will go into their correct folder.
So with my Arrucos folder selected,
let's go ahead and make sure we can see
what's happening in here.
And you can see I've got my wall in this location.
I have in my upper left hand corner,
my components that I'm gonna be working with.
And our Arrucos are gonna live
on our static mesh component walls.
So the first one we're gonna work with
is going to be my main wall viewport.
And if I go over to my cluster
and just double click on my main wall,
you'll see that come front and center right here
while my wall is selected.
Now I wanna make note here,
1760 by 880 for my aspect ratio.
You wanna make sure that you have
your resolution available
because you need to make sure that as you build this,
you're gonna need to select that viewport.
Now with that set,
I am going to make sure that my wall itself is selected
and I'm going to add in a new component.
So I'm gonna go in here and select this new component.
And the component I'm going to create
is called calibration point.
So I'm gonna type in calibration
and you can see in here, I've got calibration point.
Now this calibration point,
I'm gonna go ahead and rename CP for calibration point
and type in Arrucos.
And this is my main wall, so let's just call this MW.
Now, once that's done,
you can see I've got that section in here.
And if I move all the way over to the right side,
I've got my details panel,
scrolling on down here to calibration under LED walls,
I've got create Arrucos as an option.
So let's go ahead and hit create Arrucos
and there's my Arrucos generation options.
Now our texture width and texture height,
these are default for the entire space,
but we need this to be a little bit smaller.
So as I mentioned before, my main wall is 1760 by 880
and I need to choose an Arruco dictionary.
Now the default right now is dictionary six by six, 1000.
So I'm gonna make sure that I've got that selected
and we're gonna use that dictionary.
And from there, I've got a marker ID set of one.
This is your starting number
for your generated Arruco markers.
And then I've got a place modulus.
And my place modulus is where my LED panels are stuffed
and put together.
Now, if I'm also generating a checkerboard,
Charruco calibration board,
I can make sure that my place modulus is set to two
and that'll put a black square every other square
and generate a checkerboard for it.
And this will allow me to track both my quips,
my quadrant intersection points,
as well as the Arruco markers themselves,
giving me more points to calibrate on.
Now I'm gonna change this to one
because I don't really need that separation.
Once that's set to one, I'm gonna go ahead and hit OK.
And that's gonna generate my marker set.
Now that's gonna tell me where I wanna put that.
Instead of putting it into a textures folder,
I'm gonna go ahead and hit my calibration folder
and go into my Arruco wall textures folder.
The name itself, I don't have to worry about changing,
but do make note here of the mark one through 50.
This mark one through 50 numbers,
the generated ID for the panels
and for the Arrucos that are going to appear on this.
So I'm gonna go ahead and hit save,
and you'll see that this Arrucos are generated in here.
And it tells me that the next one I create
is going to start at 51.
So I'm gonna go ahead and hit OK here.
And then I want to make sure
that this is going to be assigned
to the correct wall viewport.
So let's go ahead and select my wall viewport
right over here.
And from here, I'm gonna move on down
in my details panel.
There is a texture replacement section.
I'm gonna go ahead and enable this.
And from here, I'm going to select
my Arrucos walls texture.
So if I type in wall, you can see that comes up here.
I've got my wall texture that is here.
And I just go ahead and assign this.
And you'll see this changes the wall here.
Now, as I go ahead and hit this enable viewport here,
I'm gonna go ahead and disable this really quickly.
And I'm gonna take a look at the wall itself.
So if I switch over to look at my wall,
I want you to see if I re-enable this,
my wall takes over and I can see
I've got Arruco markers now appearing on the wall.
Now, as I disable this,
I do wanna make sure that I jump back into the engine
because I need to build these for all of this.
So with that enabled and ready to go,
let's go ahead and build them now for my side wall.
So I'm gonna center over my side wall
and I'm gonna double click on that as well.
Now that's in my viewport.
And I wanna make sure that this is 880 by 880.
We're gonna do the same thing.
We're gonna select my side wall here,
and we're going to make sure
that this component is selected.
Go ahead and hit my add point here,
or type in calibration point.
And from here, I'm gonna rename this CP underscore Arrucos
underscore SW for sidewall.
And with that set,
I have the option here to create Arrucos again.
Now you'll note that my texture width and height
are back to my default.
I'm gonna go ahead and make sure
that these are 880 by 880.
And I'm gonna make sure
that I'm still in the same dictionary.
My marker ID automatically filled in here at 51.
But again, my place modulus is set to two.
Let's go ahead and change that to one and hit okay.
Let's choose my calibration folder
and my Arrucos wall textures folder and hit save.
And you'll note that the next number stops at 75.
Once that's here,
it tells me that my next ID is gonna start at 76.
So I'm gonna go ahead and hit okay.
And then from there,
I'm gonna move on down to my side wall
and I'm gonna go to enable viewport texture replacement.
And from here,
let's go ahead and type inside.
And you can see I've got my sidewall texture here.
I'm gonna go ahead and select that.
And as it changes in my viewport here,
it also changes on the wall.
Now I don't need to see that.
I'm gonna go ahead and continue building out my last set.
And my last set is gonna be my wild wall.
So let's go ahead and select this
and double click on my wild wall itself.
And you can see the aspect ratio on my wild wall
is 2160 by 3840.
So from here,
I'm gonna go ahead and make sure
that my wild wall is selected
and add in another component.
Let's go calibration point.
And we're gonna add that in place
and rename this one CP for calibration point, arucose.
And let's underscore this with wild wall.
So with that set, go ahead and hit enter.
And we got to create our arucose set one more time.
So let's create those arucose.
And this one is 3840 by 2160.
Now this is our width and height.
We do need to make sure that we adjust this
because our width and height are swapped.
So let's go 2160 and move to our height, which is 3840.
We do that because we're using a vertical wall
and we wanna make sure that these line up in that way.
Now my marker ID here,
I'm gonna go ahead and make sure
that these are set at one.
So I'm gonna hit that one button right there.
And once that's set, I'm ready to go.
And let's go ahead and hit okay.
Go back to my calibration section,
choose my aruko wall textures folder.
And again, you can see that this is gonna end
at my mark set at 219.
So I'm gonna go ahead and hit save.
It's gonna generate all my marker points
all the way up to 220.
And I'm gonna go ahead and hit okay here.
And now I need to move on over to my wall itself.
And again, enable my viewport texture replacement.
And from here, I'm gonna type in wild
and you can see my wild wall section in here.
And that's gonna give me my wild wall.
Now my wild wall has all of these little markers
that I can choose from as well.
One thing to note is if I look at the wild wall itself,
the wild wall's aspect ratio is a 16 by nine television.
So I have nine going across the top and 16 going down.
Whereas over here on my main wall and my side wall,
I have five by five,
which is the number of panels I have active in here.
And over on this section,
I have my five panels by my 10 panels.
So with my wall set and my arukos actually appearing
on the wall itself,
there is something else that we need to do.
We need to make a switch to be able to preview this.
So we're gonna need to build something.
Now I have my NBC asset active in here,
and you'll notice I have the option of moving over
into an event graph.
So I have my preview viewport that's available in here,
and I'm gonna move over to my event graph.
Now in my event graph, I have some options in here.
I have my event tick and event begin play.
Now I don't need an event begin play,
but I do need to keep my event tick.
So from there, I need to build some stuff.
I'm gonna move on over to my blueprint tab
that's next to my components tab, and I need a variable.
Go ahead and hit plus here to add a brand new variable.
And this is gonna be a Boolean variable,
so I don't have to change that from Boolean,
but I do need to rename this
to the replace underscore viewport underscore texture.
And as you can see, replace viewport textures.
Let's go ahead and hit enter,
and we'll make this instance editable.
So let's go ahead and click on that little eyeball
and make it stare at you.
Now, back to my event graph,
I do need to add in some nodes
to make sure that this actually works.
First thing I'm gonna do is I need to use my variables,
and a couple of things I can do.
I can either drag this right in here,
or I can right click and go ahead and search
for set replace texture for all viewports.
So you can see here,
set replace texture flag for all viewports.
That's gonna give me this section in here.
And then I can also drag that off
and go ahead and replace it that way,
or drag this pin in here
and use my get replace viewport textures.
So I'm using this to set and using this to get,
and now I'm gonna make this connection between these two.
So let's connect my replace viewport textures
to my replace option,
and let's connect my execution
all the way into this node here.
And so now I am set and ready to go.
The thing that is left to do is go ahead and compile
and save the asset, and I'm ready to go.
Now, from here,
you're gonna see that I need to make sure this works.
So to make sure that this works and is enabled,
I'm gonna go ahead and move back
to the details panel of my viewport.
Let's go ahead and hit my preview button.
You'll notice my Arucos is actually gone right now,
and I need to go back to my components panel.
To preview these, you can see that this is actually on.
Let's go ahead and make sure that these are visible,
see that they are active in my viewports right here.
Let's move this over to the side
and move to my outliner.
And with my NBC asset available,
you can see I've got some options
that are gonna go ahead and appear now that I've built this.
So that default section in my details panel
now has a replace viewport textures option.
And if I go ahead and hit this button,
you should see this happen.
So let's go ahead and switch to the wall.
So we're looking at the wall,
is I'm just gonna hit that button again,
and you can see me turn on
and turn off those textures in my viewports.
If I jump back into the engine,
while this is still enabled,
so you can see that that's still enabled,
and you can see that my viewports are visible here.
That means that I can actually see all of this work,
it's still active.
And if I jump back into the wall itself,
you can see I can just turn that on and off in real time.
Now that's gonna let me get ready for my calibration.
And by being able to see this,
it's gonna be able to show me my calibration.
Now, in order to make this show up in my viewport,
I'm gonna go back to the engine.
So I wanna go back to my lens files
and let's go ahead and choose my nodal point.
Now you can see here's my nodal point,
and you can see these are offset slightly.
So if I go back to my transparency,
you can see the alignment here for my nodal point
on my tracked object, that lines up correctly,
but my wall is not correct.
So you can see how that's slightly offset.
That's where the alignment comes into play.
That's where we're gonna align the wall to these points
so that when I adjust my transparency,
you'll be able to see that.
So in this last section that we're getting ready to do,
you'll be able to go ahead and use lens file asset editor
to actually do our RUCOS LED wall alignment.